I heard you were really excited about
watching the recent Godfather reunion I
wanted to go but they streamed it on
Facebook live did you see that the
Godfather me you know I think yeah get
everybody from the cast of The Godfather
Diane Keaton Jimmy Caan Coppola who did
most of the kind of speaking about the
film De Niro Pacino oh my god and Duvall
yeah
and they get up there and they're
talking and I mean Coppola was very
articulate but everybody else you
couldn't understand a single word they
said really James Caan would sit there I
mean I love worship over but James Caan
was gonna go I remember a time and then
they cut the Pacino but years ago I
remember that time but I you know this
[Laughter]
[Applause]
is the reunion the 45th reunion of this
legendary movie I can't understand a
question crazier you've thought a lot
about Pacino and and you you believe
that they're different machine you
worship Pacino as I think meant most
actors have to but there are different
he's changed he's had so many different
stages that's stages of Pacino yeah when
he was young
you're gonna have to pitch your voice up
very high which I don't think I could do
anymore but remember that scene in
Serpico
when he takes the kid as the rapist or
whatever he's a criminal any system you
only gonna go
he says you me gonna go for a walk
that's the two of us without cuffs what
can I say a bad word sure he goes me I'm
gonna put was you am I gonna take a walk
without cuffs you mean I'm gonna put one
in your back yeah then you turn around
was in the Scent of a Woman end of a
woman he's way down here like this he
says all his lines down here like this
and every now and then he you know he
says hoo-hah all very gravely and very
low right and now he's like this
southern character like can you see them
he's like you know I saw him in some
interview and now he's talking like this
now you got a some sort of a odd declare
sort of sound horn Leghorn
you